Các gia đeu mùi hiếu trường hạnh phúc về dự án đợ gió rối vật dài.
Còn tí cho biết hợp tất của người thống trường học các quay tự đức,
chỉ hai trường linh cấp 1 và 2 tại dự án đợ gió rối vật dài.
Trường học có khi mù khoảng 185 mưu ngồ 1 thâm,
một chết và mũ lâu với thiết kế không ra mở,
hệ đại từ hợp các khu vật học tập vui trời trải nghiệp.
Và trên thà mùi hiếu trường hạnh phúc,
chứng liên cấp 8 quay tự đức tại được gió rối vật dài khô chỉ đáp ứng sự tự tự trọc hơn
khi con trẻ được học tập nay trong quân viên dự án mà còn có phần hoàn thiệt
hệ sinh thái sống, làm việc học tập dài chi.
Chương học được đột tư kí lưỡi tự thiết kế đến trang thiết đi,
không học hiện đại thứ Việt sáng tạo, hồ bơi,
sân trời dài lựa thiết chất, phòng ảm ảm ả,
mỹ thuật, đông thời, phy phy phy phy thinh thành học tập trụ đậu,
chánh hiệp đàn giá thái trụ đề,
nhằm đáp ứng cầu học tập và phát triển tòa dịch của học sinh.
Bên cạnh đó,
các hồi tự đu cũng chú trọng và khả năng hội nhập tận cầu với chương trình viên án bữa trộn,
dú học sinh và triển đồng điều bún ký năm nay,
nói đặc biệt,
đưa đó sẽ dựa lình tảng bún chắc giúp trẻ trở thành những câu dân tòa cầu.
Đại dịch Anzaki vọng,
chương học và cầu đức sẽ mạng đến một một một chương giả dụp tinh tiến,
yêu Việt choc on em cư dân khi xong tại khu phức hợp đời gió rối vật sai.
Đồng thời,
là có hội đi Anzaki vừa các điều kiện sống tôi yêu và hoàn thiện hơn,
các tự ít dịp dụng nhằm gó phần phát triển tòa dịch hệ trẻ và năng cao trước lượng sống của cư dân.